California and New Jersey spent decades
as beacons of opportunity to the entire
world now people can't flee them fast
enough in California houses are
unaffordable needles pile up on the
streets the middle class has been
displaced by an unending wave of low pay
the illegal immigrants more than a
hundred thousand people are spending the
night tonight on the sidewalk in
California but Democratic senators Kamla
Harris and Cory Booker have a solution
smoke more weed I am proud to formally
announce that I'm signing on to the
marijuana just a snack it's the smart
thing to do it's the right thing to do
two of the last three presidents
admitted to using drugs Congress people
senators have admitted to using
marijuana but there are other
communities for which it's completely
criminalized it's it's time they were
you not only legalized marijuana in our
state's but expunge the records of those
who have been carrying that burden of
past convictions for too long all
because of their use of a drug that
otherwise should be considered legal get
high it's a civil rights victory Ethan
Berman is a California radio show
hosting joins us tonight you think great
to see you I just want to preface our
conversation by saying that I don't
think people who smoke weed should be in
jail I think the drug war hasn't worked
very well like gun control banning
something does it make it go away and I
think that alcohol is in a lot of ways
worse than marijuana so I believe all
that I'm just amazed that now the ruling
class is basically having failed to take
care of its own people is telling them
maybe you should smoke more weed and
become more passive and less concerned
by our failures I don't really think
that's an accident do you well I don't
think that they're telling us to smoke
more weed I think that people are
smoking weed and I think 80 years of
reefer madness hasn't stopped people
from smoking we agree and as you already
pointed out it's it's not worse than
alcohol Fenny what if anything there are
numerous potential medical benefits of
marijuana that we haven't even studied
because it's been a Schedule one drug we
need to get rid of that that that
classification legalized it look states
like Colorado have generated over a
quarter billion dollars a year in tax
to support the state that's pretty dumb
you're making my case for me and by the
way I think we should fully explore the
potential health benefits of Canaanites
I mean I why wouldn't we we should of
course we should and there probably are
big ones I'm all for that but why
shouldn't I be suspicious when over a
hundred thousand Californians are
sleeping outside tonight because people
like camel Harris have done a terrible
job taking care of their own people and
her solution is hey smoke more weed so
why can have more money in the tax
coffers and you will be less likely to
stage the revolution against my bad
leadership I'm not paranoid that seems
like an obvious bread and circuses ploy
to me well she's a pretty new senator so
I don't I can't she's busy but I think
elected statewide for a long time as you
know well I mean the Attorney General
but but but what we have with the
homeless population there is a lot of
care that is needed there and if some of
that revenue goal goes towards
psychological care addiction care I
think that's a wonderful thing so if the
people are already smoking marijuana or
consuming it eating it edibles whatever
CBD oil let's legalize tax regulate get
it out of the chefs how about this that
D funds the cartels because who's
bringing it across the border illegally
those are cartels you want to stop them
it's not that that's simple actually
because cartels are it's just it's just
a market and when the price of anything
goes up if you can undercut it illegally
you'll do that you see that with
cigarettes which are widely bootlegged
because of high tax rates so it's
actually not quite as simple as you're
making it but here's the point let's not
compare marijuana to alcohol I agree
it's less harmful I don't drink but
let's not do that let's compare to
sobriety being aware and awake and fully
experiencing your life and maybe
fighting back against misused power
people who are high don't do that let's
be honest and you know that well but if
they're busy drinking beer is that any
difference so if we're gonna do what
abyssion didn't work i speices specious
these people have failed their own
people and then they're encouraging us
to smoke more weed you don't see the
connection at all
I don't I don't believe anybody is
encouraging people to smoke more weed
unless you have cancer and you're not
able to keep food down during your
chemotherapy which is a wonderful side
benefit of using cannabis I don't smoke
and either tucker and but I see the
benefits met medicinally for a lot of
people who benefit also again if it's
one of those situations where people are
already doing it and criminal elements
are benefiting from it bringing it out
into the sunlight is the ideal so yeah
the government should be getting rich on
it revenue source why more weed
oh so depressing I know you agree with
me deep down Ethan we're out of time
sadly thank you